[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
the sarah lawrence college cult you do
something wrong to someone else you
victimize somebody
and then you sit there and cry for
yourself
a cult member takes the stand as her
alleged one-time leader is tried in
federal court plus competency is the
question for the wisconsin woman accused
of murdering and dismembering her lover
if there was a crime committed
probably committed it i'm satisfied for
all the reasons that i've cited the
order
and the defendant is guilty he has
pleaded guilty he does not have a
presumption of innocence so this is way
different for any other proceeding in
this courthouse the parkland school
shooting case is back in the courtroom
ahead of nicholas cruz's sentencing
phase but first the prosecution star
witness takes the stand in the murder of
lorenzen wright like brainstorming they
coming over ways of having this
you know
perform
the egg okay and what act are we talking
about the murder of the reason law and
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin the prosecution's star witness
and co-conspirator in the murder of
lorenzen wright takes the stand in
tennessee this as billy ray turner is
charged with the nba star's 2010 murder
wright was reported missing in july 2010
when he didn't return calls to family
members his body was later found in the
tennessee woods near his mother's home
seven years after his death jimmy martin
led investigators to the murder weapon
in a mississippi lake after that
defendant billy ray turner was arrested
and later charged with rights murder
prosecutors say wright's ex-wife sarah
wright recruited turner and to shoot and
kill her ex-husband they say she was
after the basketball player's life
insurance policy sheriff wright was
later charged in connection to her
ex-husband's murder she's currently
serving a 30-year sentence for
facilitating the murder on thursday and
friday martin took the stand telling
jurors shara wright recruited him to
help kill her ex-husband he testified
what happened when wright was murdered
and later how turner disposed of the gun
the bridge they had his back too
they started chasing they started firing
them chasing he jumped through the fence
he was jumping like a deer
they caught him
when he failed
did she say whether or not she had a gun
yes sir
did she say whether or not billy had a
gun
yes sir she said well from here
she said whether or not both of them
fired he said both on fire once we get
there we proceeded to uh
get rid of the pistol
tell me how that happened tell me who
did what
then they got the pills out the uh trunk
right off the ceiling on it and threw it
into the lake
and where were you when this was
happening
i was up right there was that
joining us today is la deputy public
defender philip duve and terry austin
all right phillip prosecution star
witness took the stand but did he fully
connect turner to this murder
oh i think he did ample
he gave enough evidence to convict
absolutely and you top it off with being
led to the firearm itself and you have
to understand too that there has to be
some evidence as to why this man would
just make this up is there evidence for
example of him being granted leniency
uh how did he know so much detail and
frankly most people want to ensure that
if if i'm going down as a witness in
this case i want everyone to go down
with the ship with me together and i
think in essence he fills in all the
blanks and the jury is going to be left
with an inescapable occlusion that there
was no good reason for him to make this
up all right let's let's talk about a
good reason terry credibility of a
witness who helps plan a crime is always
attacked by the defense so how did
martin hold up on cross-examination
well i think he held up pretty well on
cross-examination he is not as you say
the most credible witness he's a
convicted felon in another case he's a
co-conspirator in this case
and he has a deal with the prosecution
so you have to wonder what is his motive
here but you know his answers were
either rehearsed or he didn't remember
the details i've got to say though the
cross-examination was not done very well
i have more criticism for this defense
attorney again he was all over the place
instead of just going in a sequential
order he was trying to impeach him on
his prior interviews but it just was
very confusing and the judge actually at
one point said listen you're being
disrespectful he did this outside of the
jury but he had to reprimand him never a
good sign
absolutely not a good sign i know you've
had many comments about this defense
terry going forward i'm guessing no
passing grades here from the school of
terry austin well we'll see how it
continues though maybe he'll get better
switching now to idaho as the attorney
of one half of the so-called doomsday
duo is working to sever ties from the
accused killer's co-defendant at a
hearing friday chad dabel's attorneys
argued uncertainty surrounding his
co-defendant's case is reason enough to
split his trial from wife laurie
valodebel both face charges in the
deaths of lori's two children jj valo
and tyler ryan end in the death of
dabel's first wife tammy the pair were
dubbed the doomsday duo for their shared
belief in the end of days the couple was
married in 2019 just weeks after dave
bell's wife mysteriously died in her
sleep and valodebel's youngest children
went missing in june 2020 the remains of
jj and tyler were finally recovered on
chad dabell's property since then there
have been questions surrounding
valodebel's ability to stand trial after
she was initially deemed incompetent the
outcome of a recent psychiatric
evaluation has not yet been released
chad dabel's attorneys now say his case
should move forward without his second
wife
i don't want any delay judge i need a
decision one way or the other as to
whether this is going to be severed
because i have a significant amount of
preparation that i'm going to need to do
and there's going to be an impact which
way this goes
and this has been pending for f this
motion's been pending for five months
and it hasn't changed in five months ms
valo day bell's position in terms of
where she's at we have no certainty as
to where it's going to be in another
five or six months
and i think it's inappropriate to put mr
day bell hanging in this situation
with the idea that we don't have any
certainty is where this is going given
that judge there's a difference between
delay and uncertainty and given the
uncertainty your honor i would
respectfully ask this court to sever the
cases
still ahead on law and crime daily a
wisconsin woman compare it to the likes
of jeffrey dump as investigators say she
murdered and dismembered her lover after
sex but first the parkland school
shooting a hefty settlement is reached
with the victims families just weeks
before nicolas cruz is set to be
sentenced
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily an
update now on the delhi parkland school
shooting the families of the victims
reach a monumental settlement with the
department of justice to the tune of
more than 127 million dollars this comes
just weeks ahead of the sentencing phase
for the man responsible nicholas cruz in
october cruz pled guilty to all 17
counts of murder and 17 counts of
attempted murder in relation to the
shooting in early 2018. the families of
those affected reach the settlement
based on the fbi's failure to stop cruz
despite receiving tips about the
shooting weeks before the attack cruz
faces the death penalty or life in
prison to be determined at his
sentencing set to begin in early april
on friday at a status hearing attorneys
discuss questions for jury selection
with the judge saying this case is
different than most since it's just the
penalty phase and not proving guilt
this is a penalty phase there's no
presumption of innocence here the
defendant is guilty he has pleaded
guilty knowledge of the defendant in
this case is not really something that
is is going to be instructive as to
these jurors abilities to serve it's
whether they can listen and
render
their opinion as to what sentence should
be he has pled guilty
he does not have a presumption of
innocence so this is way different for
any other proceeding in this courthouse
so we would obviously i said i took this
from the last one we would take that out
but i'm assuming that you all would want
me to
still
um instruct them on the law which would
be unreasonable you know a reasonable
doubt and what that means
because i have to be able to say more
than can you be fair and impartial can
you follow the law this is the law and
who can follow who cannot
let's bring back l.a county public
defender philip dube and terry austin to
discuss this landmark settlement by the
doj
terry what were some of the arguments
that led to this settlement and what's
your reaction to this large amount
well it is a large amount but you have
to remember it was 17 deaths 16 of those
families sued one decided not to sue but
was the fbi negligent that is the issue
was it reasonable for them to ignore the
tip that they got that five weeks before
the shooting there's a call saying
that cruz bought guns and that he wanted
to go and shoot up a school this is
something they really should have
responded to so i don't think it was
reasonable that they didn't obviously
they have boarded other attempts but not
this time and this was such a huge case
and frankly i think the
millions of dollars is not going to
obviously do anything for these families
because they'll never have their
children back terry now i'm interested
to see how that one family who didn't
sue is reacting to the settlements but
that's probably for another day philip
when we look ahead to the sentencing
phase what issues could he run into when
it comes to finding a jury
oh they're gonna want a jury that
has kids grandkids you want bonus moms
on that jury you want foster parents you
want pediatricians you want people who
work regularly with kids
teachers youth coaches clergy that type
of thing because those are the types of
jurors who could embrace somebody like
nicholas cruz as one of their own and
not set him free but certainly not
condemn him to death yeah absolutely one
side looking for the death penalty the
other side looking for life in prison
it's going to be interesting but of
course law and crime daily will bring in
the update as it comes in coming up on
law and crime daily emotional testimony
on friday from the sarah lawrence sex
cult trials key witness for lawrence
rey's sex trafficking charge adam classo
brings us details straight from the
courtroom plus prosecutors say she
murdered her lover cut off his head and
sexually assaulted the remains but is
taylor show business competent to stand
trial that's still ahead on law and
crime daily
[Music]
welcome back a wisconsin woman appears
in court after she's charged with
murdering and decapitating her lover
long crime daily sierra gillespie joins
us now with the latest developments
the same woman who told investigators
they would have fun trying to find all
the dismembered body parts of her victim
is now ordered a competency hearing
before court proceedings can continue
it was 24 year old shad thyron's mother
who found his decapitated head in a
bucket at the bottom of her stairway
investigators say thyrion's lover 24
year old taylor she business is
responsible for his murder sexual
assault and dismemberment shabinis
appeared in court virtually on thursday
as her defense attorney motioned for a
competency evaluation but if you blinked
you missed her
mr business isn't here today she doesn't
seem to be engaging directly with the
court i can't see her face
i can see her but she's not looking into
the camera
now she is all right
instead she business stood in a cell at
the brown county jail with her arms
crossed she's being held on a two
million dollar cash bond last month she
business told investigators she went
quote crazy when she began choking
thyrion during sex while she didn't plan
to kill him she said she was quote
already this far and liked it after he
was dead she performed sexual acts on
thyrian's body she later dismembered the
remains putting a leg and foot in her
vehicle but leaving the victim's head
behind in a bucket she told
investigators quote i can't believe i
left the head though
she also told investigators that she had
become paranoid after smoking meth and
shooting up trazadone showbusiness's
attorney requested a competency
evaluation saying he's concerned about
her ability to assist in her own defense
who's going to represent
mr business in this very important case
and it's and it's getting a little bit
confusing
she's making some of these choices
to allow it to be confusing on her own
and i'm satisfied that that too
gives
the court a stern or
reason to doubt
the results of that competency
evaluation will be discussed at an
upcoming hearing set for april fourth
shabbis is set to appear again in court
next week on march 22 for her adjourned
initial appearance reporting in green
bay sierra gillespie lawn crime network
all right l.a county deputy public
defender philip dubay and co-host terry
austin are back to break down this
bizarre case of death and dismemberment
terry walk us through competency how
will it affect the case if she goes to
trial any potential plea deals
well this is truly a bizarre case and
under wisconsin law if she lacks the
substantial mental capacity to
understand those proceedings and to
assist in her own defense she could be
deemed incompetent and that will mean
there will be no trial until she's
deemed competent so she will be in a
mental institution they will be taking
tests they will try to determine whether
or not she's competent we've seen this
before in idaho obviously the laurie de
belvallo case where she has now been
deemed incompetent for over 180 days so
we don't know how long this will last if
she's deemed incompetent but if she
comes back competent and they go to
trial at some point there's always the
defense of insanity all right phillip
let's talk about that defense uh because
in my mind there has to be an insanity
defense here right and again i don't
think there's any way the prosecution
prosecution can argue against that or
can they
well it depends uh you know the standard
in wisconsin is that they have to prove
or the defense has to show a that she in
fact uh has a mental illness a mental
defect and typically that has to be a
settled uh psychotic spectrum disorder
separate from a drug-induced psychosis
so you can't just get loaded and high on
meth and opioids commit a crime and then
cry insanity you have to have a true
settled mental illness independent of
any drug-induced psychosis that you
might have but once you show that then
she has to show that she lacked the
capacity to appreciate the wrongfulness
of her conduct or to conform to the law
well let's assume she can make out the
fact that she has a settled psychotic
spectrum disorder her problem is is that
she was able to adequately clean up the
scene afterwards dispose of the head
clean up so it clearly shows that she
could appreciate the wrongfulness of her
conduct and could otherwise conform to
the law all right maybe this isn't as
black and white as we originally thought
but of course we'll get more updates on
taylorship business as the case
continues when we come back a firsthand
account of life on the inside of the
sarah lawrence college cult long crime
network's adam classville breaks down a
former cult member's testimony from the
federal courthouse in new york
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
federal court is back in session for
accused sarah lawrence college cult
leader lawrence ray this after rey
suffered back-to-back seizures on
tuesday delaying the trial for several
days ray faces 17 charges including
racketeering and sex trafficking among
others all this stems from allegations
dating back to 2010 when prosecutors say
ray moved in with his daughter who was a
student at sarah lawrence college
officials say ray befriended several
students and abused them for upwards of
10 years prosecutors say he extorted
money from the students forced them into
sex and prostitution and even held
manipulative therapy sessions on friday
one time cult member claudia jury took
the stand detailing she endured at the
hands of rey
our own adam classfeld was at the
federal courthouse on friday as jury
testified he tells us jury testified she
was scared for her life while under
raised control
the key government witness claudia drury
is at the heart of the sex trafficking
claim against larry ray claudia drury
testified that she became a prostitute
at larry ray's behest and made 2.5
million dollars
from sex work for him
there was very a graphic testimony in
court she basically
said that larry ray
on top of
the central allegation also physically
abused her
said that
he slapped me in the face so hard i fell
over
pulled my hair strangled me suffocated
me hit me she said that he threatened to
put me in jail numerous times he
threatened to kill me on a memorable
occasion he threatened to cut my face
he threatened to have me abducted and
dropped in the middle east
he threatened to blackmail people i knew
he threatened to beat up my father
the defense is likely to argue the
prosecution didn't meet their burden
because let's face it what else do they
have in this case but at what point do
you think they start thinking about the
sentencing and is now too soon
oh
let me just tell you they have a very
very strong case and usually when you
argue that they haven't met their burden
without asserting any affirmative
defense that's all you have really to
argue to the jury there is a very
aggressive movement afoot in this
country to go after sex traffickers
there is a very serious heightened
awareness to go after these people and
as we saw in the elaine maxwell case
it's not just men they're going after
the women madams who are also putting uh
the victims of sex work um
quite aggressively for lack of a better
term i don't think there's much hope for
this man what he should do is try to as
a hail mary if it's all at all possible
negotiate a settlement but i predict
whatever that settlement is is going to
be in the very high double digits
absolutely now terry we have seen
several extremely disturbing videos
already what type of impact will these
videos have on the jury
listen i think the fact that we have
these videos means that we will probably
get a conviction the evidence is just so
overwhelming and this is unlike many of
the other sex trafficking cases we've
seen phillip mentioned gelane maxwell
also harvey weinstein also bill cosby
the difference here is that we have this
video we actually see him grooming these
individuals we don't see the actual
sexual acts but this is more than enough
for a jury to say this individual is
guilty and the testimony of the two
witnesses we've heard so far claudia
drury and santos rosario they both are
saying very similar things that he
subjected them to violence so very
damning evidence yeah i think that's
going towards one outcome only and one
come only thank you both and thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you